So we were talking last time about,
uh,
the planet,
the objects in the solar system.
And we'd gone through kind
of two of the three stages,
uh,
of the scientific method as it's applied
to observational science rather than
experimental science.
And the first thing was
just making observations,
finding a bunch of things.
And so I gave you a little slide show,
uh,
depicting some of the objects in our
solar system and after observations,
the next thing,
uh,
to do his classification last year.
Fication and,
uh,
we did some of that too.
And I divided all these objects that
had been discovered into six categories.
Uh,
and then once you've done that,
once you have some categories
that kind of makes sense.
Uh,
then the next thing is to interpret these
results and to try and explain where
these categories come from,
how they arise,
and uh,
actually figure something out.
And,
uh,
I've,
described that his interpretation
and I want to offer you a little bit of
interpretation about what we found out
about the solar system.
Now,
uh,
I only want to explain,
some of the classifications.
This is actually a common thing to do
when you find a whole bunch of different
things,
and you've got 12 classes
in three subclasses,
in two exceptions,
uh,
you kind of want to explain the beak
features first and then worry about the
little things later.
This is commonly done.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to talk about a old Lee,
the,
uh,
inner terrestrial planet.
Uh,
you'll recall that these are small,
rocky,
uh,
things in a relatively short orbit,
and uh,
and contrast them with the outer planets,
the Jovian,
the Jupiter like planet,
uh,
which are large and have not only rocks,
but also lots of ice and gas,
uh,
and these things,
are and wider orbits.
Uh,
but the orbits of both of these are
basically more or less circular,
not precisely circular.
They're actually elliptical,
but,
but quite close.
Uh,
and they're all in the same plane.
That is to say they're all
going around the same way.
Uh,
there's nothing that's going to,
whoops,
there's nothing that's going
this way instead of this way.
So there's circular and Co Planer.
Uh,
and,
uh,
let's try for an explanation
of those particular features.
Okay.
So this would be,
uh,
something like a theory
of planetary formation,
how the planets formed,
why they get that way.
This word theory is a serious problem.
Uh,
this is one of the foremost examples
of word that means something different.
When scientists use it,
then when normal people use it,
uh,
in scientific parlance,
a theory is something
which has a lot of support,
which explains a lot of
observed or experimental fact,
uh,
in everyday life.
Of course,
a theory mean to wild gas,
uh,
the difference.
So there's a pretty stark difference
between those two definitions.
Uh,
this gets our friends,
the evolutionary biologists and all kinds
of trouble because they keep talking
about the theory of evolution.
Uh,
and a certain segment of
society interprets that as
the wild gas of evolution.
And this creates various
kinds of difficulties.
The problem is there isn't another
word that one can readily use for what,
what the science,
uh,
definition of this.
You could use paradigm,
you could use scenario,
uh,
these are,
kind of ugly,
uh,
sorts of words.
So I think we're stuck with theory,
but I mean this in the sense of something
that explains a lot of facts rather
than in the sense of wild guess.
Okay.
So here we go.
Uh,
theory of planetary formation.
So the idea is that the planet form,
uh,
from a disc of material around the sun,
around the sun,
so the sun and the planet,
uh,
are created out of a collapsing cloud.
The cloud collapses.
Some parts of the cloud are rotating
that prevents them from collapsing.
And so you have a situation after a
while where you have a sort of star like
thing in the middle and then a
kind of disk of stuff around it.
Uh,
so this is a side view and in the top few,
all these things are in orbit here.
And,
uh,
this disc consists of basically
the same material as the sun,
which is to say lots of gas,
uh,
by which I mean hydrogen
and helium in particular.
Uh,
some,
uh,
ice,
of course when it's in a star,
it's all melted.
Uh,
but these are elements like carbon,
nitrogen,
oxygen,
that go into making isis.
And a little bit of a
heavier elements that could,
if you put them all together,
a form,
dust and rocks and things like that.
A little heavier,
uh,
element,
things like silicon and iron.
Uh,
so that's what the sun consists stuff.
and so does this disc
orbiting around them.
What happens,
uh,
in the disk,
things,
uh,
gradually stick together.
So rather than having
individual atoms or molecules,
the molecules and atoms sort of run
into each other form dust grains,
the dust grains run,
or ice crystals or whatever.
Those run into each
other for bigger things.
And you gradually make a bigger things
as the little things collide with each
other and stick.
Uh,
so in the disc,
things gradually stick together
and become tiny little objects,
which are sometimes given
the name planetesimals.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then the planetesimals bump
into each other and stick a stick,
uh,
together,
until you've got a situation,
uh,
where in each region,
each CCO each orbit,
each distance from the sun.
Uh,
you've called last everything
into one large object.
Uh,
and so you end up with
one big object in each,
uh,
region by which I mean
distance from the sun,
distance from the star.
And this explains the orbits
because since it's Co,
since these large objects have been
created by running a lot of small objects
together,
uh,
the,
lip electricity of any of the elliptical
part of the orbit of any of these
things tend to cancel out because one of
these objects will be elliptical in one
direction or another will be
elliptical and another direction.
If you put them all together,
they'll grab that orbit
will tend to be circular.
Similarly,
some of the objects will be going up
out of the plane of the solar system.
Some will be going down,
but you'll run them together and they'll
all end up with kind of a similar
circular co Planar orbits.
So,
uh,
makes uh,
approximately that's the approximate side.
Circular,
a Co planar orbits.
So that's good cause that's one of
the things we're trying to explain.
And there is an expected difference
between how this works out in the inner
parts of the solar system and how it
works out in the outer parts of the solar
system.
In the inner solar system,
uh,
the ice and gas and,
the planetesimals,
uh,
evaporates and does not become part
of the planet that gets formed.
And so the planet are only,
uh,
the rocky parts.
They actually hold on
to a little bit of the,
uh,
of the ice and gas button,
but not very much.
Uh,
whereas in the outer solar system,
the ice is frozen and so
it behaves just like rocks.
And so planet have rocks and ice.
This means that they're
substantially more massive.
And if they're sufficiently massive,
then they have enough
gravity to hold onto the gas.
Also,
uh,
two gas as well.
It's also true than in
the outer solar system.
There's more volume,
there's stuff than,
so there's more stuff to build the
planets out of in the first place.
Um,
okay.
And so this,
uh,
nicely explained the difference between
the inner solar system and the outer
solar system.
We build these things
up out of little chunks,
uh,
but in the inner solar system,
the temperature is high enough
that the chunks of ice evaporate.
And so you can't build
them up out of that.
And so you get much,
much smaller things,
uh,
made almost entirely out of rocks.
In contrast to the outer solar
system where you have enough ice,
you build much bigger planets,
and in some cases you hang on
to a lot of the gas as well.
So this is interesting because it makes
a prediction about how other solar
systems ought to look,
namely that this difference between
inner planets and outer planets ought to
exist everywhere,
uh,
that,
planetary systems,
there should be a general feature because
there's nothing what I've said so far
that unique to the sun.
So,
uh,
planetary systems,
should have,
uh,
uner rocky planets
and outer,
uh,
a Jupiter like planets,
sort of gas plus ice.
So I took planet much bigger.
And the dividing line between these two,
uh,
kinds of planet,
is determined by temperature.
Okay.
Because there'll be some temperature
where those ice things melt.
And uh,
therefore you don't expect it to be
at the same distance away from a star.
You expect it to be at the
place where the is the same.
Therefore,
if you have a very bright star,
Hot Star,
uh,
you'll have inner planets out further
from that star inner type terrestrial
planets will go out further.
And if you have a very dim,
faint star,
a which doesn't generate as much heat,
the gas planets will,
uh,
the dividing line between the gas planets
and the terrestrial planets will be
much closer in a,
so the dividing line is
determined by temperature,
uh,
Hanse by,
the,
uh,
luminosity,
the amount of energy given off,
uh,
of the star.
Yeah.
So now this tells us what
we're supposed to do next.
Uh,
namely,
uh,
go out and find a whole bunch of other
solar systems and verify this prediction.
Namely that if you've got
really bright hot star,
you ought to have rocks out
fairly far in the solar system.
Whereas if you have a dim star,
you'll have Jupiter like
things coming in much closer.
Uh,
and uh,
so that's what I want to talk about was,
uh,
now is how people went about doing
this and what the results were.
And I'll tell you the
punchline in advance,
uh,
which is that this totally doesn't work,
but it's an obvious prediction from our
theory of planet formation that came
about,
uh,
by an examination of what was
going on in our own solar system.
Okay.
So observing exoplanets,
how'd you find these things?
Uh,
and you'll recall we started
down this track last,
uh,
in the last lecture.
Uh,
the,
uh,
key point here is that stars move to,
okay.
It's not just the planet
going around a star.
It's the planet and the star both go
around the center of mass of the system.
And the stars moved too.
You can't see the planets independently.
And there was a little equation.
The velocity of the star times the mass
of the star is equal to the velocity of
the planet times the mass of the planet.
This is a,
basically an equation of momentum.
Uh,
the distance of the star to the center
of mass times its mass is equal to the
distance of the planet to the center
of mass times the mass of the planet.
This is kind of a definition
of the center of mass.
And,
uh,
sometimes you don't want to deal with the
individual velocities or distances you
want to deal with the total
velocity or distances.
And so that's just defined where if
you want to talk about the total,
that's obviously just
d star Plus d planet.
Uh,
similarly for the total velocity
and the total mass.
Okay.
And that's just,
you know,
defining terms.
And then in order to relate
these distances to things
that have shown up in our
equations in Kepler's third law,
uh,
it's,
it's a true,
that the maximum value
of the total distance,
that is to say the distance between these
things can vary because they can be in
elliptical orbits.
Uh,
sometimes they're closer than others.
And if you take the maximum
distance between them,
that's the maximum d total.
That's a,
that's the semi major access of the orbit.
Uh,
and,
uh,
now for nearly circular orbits
as the planet to turn out to be,
uh,
then d total is always the
same because if it's circular,
the distance between them doesn't ferry.
Uh,
so then Dee,
uh,
Dee total is more or less equal to the
Sami major access because it's always the
same,
therefore it's always
near its own maximum.
Uh,
and then you can also say something
interesting about the velocity,
the velocity.
Well,
that's the definition of velocity.
Velocity is miles per hour
or something like that.
So it's distance per time.
And let's take a time period
of one orbital period.
And it asked the question,
how far does something
go in one orbital period?
While it goes all the
way around it's orbit.
Uh,
and you may recall from high
school geometry that if you know,
uh,
the,
the radius of a circle,
you also know its circumference.
The circumference is the distance.
It would have to travel that
to two Pi Times the radius.
This is this basic fact from geometry.
Uh,
and so that's two Pi Times the distance
in this case to send me major access.
Uh,
but this is only true for
nearly circular orbits.
And the reason is that in
highly elliptical orbits of
the velocity changes by a
substantial amount of moves
much faster when it's closer.
Uh,
and so you can only really
define what the overall,
uh,
velocity of the thing is if you've
got a nearly circular orbit.
But in that case,
as is true for planets,
uh,
there's two Pi over p gives
you a value for velocity.
Now,
uh,
so we have another little equation here.
V Equals two pi a over p.
This is an important one.
Uh,
so you'll,
you'll want to remember that.
Um,
and I should say,
which kind of visa and A's.
Remember up here there's v Starr,
VPV total,
all these different kinds of things.
Uh,
what do I actually mean by that?
And,
and the,
it can mean any of them,
but it has to be consistent.
So if you're dealing with
the velocity of the star,
then a is equal to,
uh,
d star.
Remember,
these are all nearly circular orbits.
So,
uh,
d isn't going to change.
Uh,
and if you've,
if you're dealing with a v of the planet,
then a is equal to d of the planet.
And that is approximately
equal to d total,
uh,
because the,
the mass of the planet is so low that
almost all the motion in the system comes
from the planet.
So,
uh,
you can also deal with a v total,
which is equal to v planet.
MMM.
And so,
uh,
all these things go together,
but if you're worried about
the velocity of the star,
you have to be careful because
it's not a of the orbit as a whole.
It's just the tiny piece of the orbit,
uh,
that,
that involves the motion of the star.
Okay.
Uh,
let's do an example.
How fast does the Earth move?
Uh,
v equals two pi a over P,
uh,
well,
we know a is equal to
one astronomical unit.
P is equal to one year,
uh,
for the Earth's orbit.
And so,
uh,
the velocity of the earth is two
Pi astronomical units per year.
Pretty straight forward.
Uh,
but not very informative
because we don't have a,
a feeling for what,
for measuring velocities and
astronomical units per year.
Uh,
there's a joke in a,
uh,
kind of physics joke that you convert all
velocities into furlongs per fortnight
just to be annoying.
Uh,
but let's not do that.
Let's convert it instead into meters per
second because then we have a hope of
understanding what's going on.
Uh,
v is equal to two Pi one astronomical
unit is 1.5 times 10 to the 11 meters a
and a year is three times
10 to the seven seconds.
Uh,
Pi divided by three is one,
uh,
two times 1.5 is three,
10 to the 11 divided by 10 to the seven.
11 minus seven is tend to is four.
So this is 10 to the
four meters per second.
That's 30 kilometers per second.
So we move right along
as we go around the sun.
Uh,
if you did this for Jupiter,
uh,
plugged in the various values for Jupiter,
I won't actually do that calculation.
You can do it on,
on your own.
You're discover the Jupiter moves
about half as fast as the earth.
So it goes around 15
kilometers per second.
That's 1.5 times 10 to the
four meters per second.
So now we can ask the question,
how fast does the sun move in
response to the orbit of the,
uh,
of these planets?
So,
uh,
how fast is the solar
motion induced by Jupiter?
Okay.
And now we go back to
this momentum equation.
Uh,
velocity of Jupiter Times the mass of
Jupiter is equal to the velocity of the
Sun Times the mass of the sun.
What we want to know is
the velocity of the sun.
And so that is equal to
the velocity of Jupiter,
which we just calculated,
uh,
times the mass of Jupiter
divided by the mass of the sun.
1.5 times 10 to the four.
That's the velocity of Jupiter
mass of Jupiter as it happens.
I think I wrote this down last time.
Two Times 10 to the 27
kilograms mass of the sun.
Two Times 10 to the 30.
Okay.
Two's capsule.
Obviously.
Uh,
we get 1.5 times 10 to the
four times 10 to the 27.
That's 10 to the 31.
10 to the 31 divided by 10 to the 30 is
10 to the one is equal to 15 meters per
second,
not kilometers.
Now meters.
And so the sun,
the Jupiter moves 15
kilometers per second.
The Sun moved 15 meters per second.
That makes perfect sense because the sun
is a thousand times more massive than
Jupiter.
So it has to be going a
thousand times more slowly.
So instead of moving at some
number of kilometers per second,
it's moving at some numbers
of meters per second.
This,
it turns out,
can be detected with modern equipment.
Uh,
detect a both.
Let's say,
uh,
in distance starts you can see things
that move by 15 meters a second.
Uh,
we'll come back to,
to how that's done in a minute.
How about the earth solar
motion due to Earth.
Now you might think this is going to be
bigger because the velocity of earth is
bigger than the velocity of Jupiter,
but of course the mass is much,
much smaller.
So we have an earth,
earth is equal to a m sun.
The Sun where visa now means
the emotion induced by earth.
This number is bigger
than it was for Jupiter,
but this number is a whole lot smaller.
And so the overall effect is that,
uh,
the sun is going to be smaller.
Uh,
the earth earth over,
uh,
m son,
that's three times 10 to the fourth.
That's the velocity mass of the earth.
As it turns out,
as six times 10 to the
24 meters per second.
Uh,
the sun down here at
two times 10 to the 30,
same son,
six over two is three,
three times three is 10.
So we get 10 times 10 to
the four times 10 to the 24,
over 10 to the 30,
uh,
10 to the one,
one five,
29 over 30,
that's 10 to the minus one is equal to
one 10th of a meter per second or 10
centimeters per second.
So that's much,
much slower than the sun moves.
In response.
Did you put her why?
Because the earth is so much less massive.
So 15 meters a second,
uh,
for,
as a result of Jupiter,
only 10 centimeters,
a second,
a 10th of a meter per second,
uh,
as a result of,
earth and with current technology,
uh,
things that slow are not detectable yet
in other around other stars.
So we have a situation and this was what
was happening about 10 years ago where,
uh,
instruments have been developed that could
in principle see the reflex motion of
stars due to planets like Jupiter,
but weren't yet capable of seeing,
uh,
the motion of stars.
Uh,
the motion of stars due
to planets like earth.
But we expect that solar systems
Oughta have planets like Jupiter.
And so people went out to try and look,
all right,
how do you find,
how do you observe these things?
And now if you've taken
high school physics,
you will recall perhaps something
called the doppler shift.
This is the key.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is a way of measuring velocity.
And it turns out,
oddly enough,
that velocities are some of the most
easy and straight forward things to
measure,
uh,
in astronomical objects because you
can determine them by the doppler ship.
Uh,
and so just to remind you,
or,
uh,
to inform you if you
haven't seen this before,
and there's,
there's,
uh,
some help sheets and things that
you can look at about this too.
Uh,
light,
uh,
is characterized
bye.
It's wavelength,
uh,
which is usually given
the Greek letter lambda,
uh,
and a light that is something like four
times 10 to the minus seven meters of
wave link has units of length.
Uh,
this looks blue to us,
a light that is,
uh,
let's color code this
for your convenience.
A five times 10 to the minus
seven meters looks green,
uh,
seven times 10 to the minus
seven meters a kind of looks red.
Uh,
longer wavelengths are
what we call infrared
and shorter wave lengths,
uh,
that,
that we can't see are called ultra violet.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
so ultra violet up here,
and if you get really,
really long,
uh,
if you have like meter wave lengths,
that's radio waves out here.
And if you have really short wave lengths,
uh,
those are x rays and gamma rays.
So all of these kinds of radiation
are basically the same thing called
electromagnetic radiation.
Again,
there's a help sheet,
uh,
these are all electromagnetic radiation
at what kind of radiation it is,
depends on the wavelength.
Uh,
and the key to the doppler shift
is that the observed wavelength
changes,
uh,
depending on the relative motion of
the thing in meeting the light in the
observer
motion of source and observer
in particular,
if they're moving toward each other,
uh,
then the wavelength gets shorter.
Yeah.
And if they're moving
away from each other,
the wavelength gets longer.
Do you feel an equation coming on?
Yeah,
because obviously this is
going to need to be quantified,
right?
You know,
how much shorter,
how much longer.
Uh,
but,
but before we do that,
let me just point out that,
uh,
this motion towards is sometimes
called a blue shift because it makes,
it pushes the light from the red end of
the visual spectrum towards the blue.
Uh,
and this kind of thing here,
the emotion away from each
other's called the red shift.
Okay.
Uh,
and uh,
let me,
uh,
let me show you why this is true.
Before I,
before I write down the equation,
let's see.
Uh,
it's just,
uh,
let me get out of that
and try this one instead.
It's just a property of a,
of how waves what.
So,
uh,
look what's happened.
If the thing is stationary
there in the middle,
but emitting the waves,
then the waves propagate
equally in all directions.
In both observers see the same
distance between success of re waves.
That is to say the same wavelength.
Uh,
and you can see that there.
Then when the thing is
moving in one direction,
uh,
each successive wave is emitted
a little bit closer to one,
a observer and a little further
away from the other observer.
And so because the waves are
emitted a at different places,
the way front here,
uh,
Po,
I'll wait until this cycle goes through.
Again,
the wave fronts for this observer,
uh,
are closer to each other and
the wavelength looks shorter.
So when the thing is coming towards
you that submitting the wave,
uh,
it looks shorter to the
observer it's going towards,
whereas for this guy,
uh,
the waves,
each successive wave is emitted
a little bit further away.
And so the wave fronts,
uh,
are further away from each
other when they pass him in,
the wavelength of becomes longer.
So that's the kind of conceptual,
uh,
thing that's going on.
And the key thing is that the velocity
that that's relevant here is velocity
toward and away from you.
If the thing is going sideways,
it doesn't make any difference.
Uh,
and so it's not actually
velocity that you observe,
uh,
by looking at the doppler shift,
it's,
uh,
it's radio velocity,
which is the technical term for,
is the thing coming towards you or
moving away from you and how fast is it
coming towards you?
And how fast is it's moving away from you.
Okay.
Let me,
uh,
turn this off here.
Stuff.
Hi.
All right,
so here's the equation
for that.
Let's see here.
Lamb does the wavelength.
I'll explain all these terms in a minute.
Uh,
and this is important,
and the terms mean the following things.
Uh,
this is radio velocity.
Okay.
Uh,
and it's positive when
it's going away from you.
It's negative when it's going towards you
and it's zero when it's going sideways
and it's a velocity of 10 meters per
second or whatever the appropriate units
have for launch per fortnight or
whatever the appropriate units are.
A,
the only restriction on the route units
is it has to be in the same unit as the
thing in the denominator here.
That see,
that's the speed of light.
That's three times 10 to
the eight meters per second.
Maybe we should have you work it
out in for logs per fortnight.
Uh,
no,
we won't do that.
Uh,
but,
uh,
as long as the velocity here is expressed
in the same terms as you expressed the
speed of light,
then the units we'll work out.
Uh,
this lambda to with the
little zero at the bottom,
uh,
is the rest.
Yeah,
wave length.
So that's the wavelength
you would observe,
uh,
from,
from whatever light source
electromagnetic radiation source you have.
If nothing was moving.
And Delta Lambda,
this is not delta times lambda.
That's one symbol.
Uh,
confusingly enough.
Delta always means change.
Uh,
for those,
you may remember this from Calculus.
Uh,
if you've taken calculus,
Delta always means change.
So this is a change in velocity.
Uh,
change,
sorry,
change in the wavelength.
And it is defined such that the
observed wavelength is equal to the rest
wavelength,
plus the change in the wavelength
induced by the radio velocity.
So now look how this works.
If this side of the equation is negative,
if it's coming towards you,
uh,
then this quantity is negative.
That means this quantity is negative.
That means the observed wavelength
is shorter than the rest wavelength,
which is exactly how it's supposed to be.
When you come towards you,
it's blue shifted.
The wavelengths get shorter.
Uh,
similarly,
if this is going,
if something's going away from you,
then Vesa bar is positive.
This is positive,
and you end up with a longer wavelength.
Okay?
All right.
Example,
how fast you have to go
to turn a red light green.
This is potentially useful.
Uh,
should you ever be pulled
over for running a,
running a,
a red light?
Uh,
you can just say it look green.
how fast,
uh,
to make a red light green,
and let's call a green light five
times 10 to the minus seven meters,
a red light is seven times
10 to the minus seven meters.
So Delta Lambda had better be equal to
seven minus five times 10 to the minus
seven a,
that's two times 10 to the minus seven,
uh,
again,
in meters.
And we want this to be negative because
we want lamb does zero to be the red.
That's what it would be
like if nothing was moving.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we want lambda observed to be green,
and lamb to observed equals
lambda zero plus Delta Lambda.
So this had better be minus two
times 10 to the minus seven meters.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
Delta Lambda over lambda zero,
that's minus two times
10 to the minus seven,
over five times 10 to the minus seven.
So that's minus two fifths is equal to
the radio velocity over the speed of
light.
So if you're going at minus two fifths,
the speed of light,
then the red light looks green.
Uh,
Nan,
the minus just means you have
to be moving toward that light.
Uh,
now two things about this.
First of all,
don't use this as an excuse because it'll
cost you much more in the ticket for
going over the speed limit.
Uh,
if you're going at two
fifths of the speed of life,
second of all,
uh,
be wary of this a little bit
because there is in fact changes,
uh,
to the equation that happens when you're
going close to the speed of light.
And we'll talk about that
when we get to relativity.
Uh,
and so this was just an example of,
of,
of how this works out.
Uh,
it,
but,
uh,
when you're dealing with
the motions of stars,
15 meters per second,
10 centimeters or second,
you're nowhere near the speed of light.
And so the equation that I
wrote down is actually fine.
So what do you expect to see
when you're looking at a star,
which has a planet in orbit around it?
Looking at a star,
at a star in some kind of orbit.
So here's the radio velocity
as a function of time.
And the key thing about orbits is that
the radio velocity changes because first
the things coming towards you.
Then later in its orbit,
it turns around and goes the other way.
Then it comes back and
it comes towards you,
turns around and goes other way.
So the radio velocity will change from
positive to negative and back as the
object first comes towards you,
then away from you.
And so it'll look like this.
Yeah,
if you make a whole bunch
of observations of this,
and it turns out that for circular orbits,
uh,
this is a sign wave.
Uh,
and,
uh,
if you were to observe this,
you could observe
directly from such a plot.
If you made repeated observations of,
uh,
of the radio velocity of a
star or some other thing in,
or bet you could observe two things.
First of all,
you would immediately be able to
tell what the orbital period is.
That's the amount of time.
This is a time axis.
It takes,
uh,
for the object to come back to
the same place in the orbit,
uh,
for a second time.
Second of all,
you could tell something
about what the velocity is.
Uh,
the amplitude of this sign wave
is,
uh,
something to do with the overall velocity
because that's the maximum velocity it
has coming towards you.
Uh,
but you have to be a little careful here
because that's only true if the object,
uh,
if the orbit is edge on,
let me explain what I mean by that.
We'll come back to this later.
If the orbits going this way,
then it never comes towards
you or goes away from you.
It's always going sideways.
If on the other hand,
the orbits going this way,
then first it comes towards you,
then it goes away from you.
Uh,
and if it's somewhere in between,
you only see part of the motion of
the orbit in terms of radio velocity.
So this amplitude is v
if the orbit is edge on,
if not,
v is going to be more than that because
you're only seeing part of the motion.
That's a detail we'll come back to later.
So this is what you expect to see.
Uh,
if there's a planet going around the star
and if you have enough sensitivity and
your measurements of the doppler shift
to be able to actually see a that motion.
Okay.
So here's what they saw.
This,
uh,
is uh,
a star called 51 Pegasus in
the constellation of pegasis.
It is a solar analog,
so called,
uh,
by which they mean it's as about
as much like the sun as they can,
as you can find if you go
out and look at other stores.
So it's very,
very much like the sun.
Uh,
this is a radio velocity curve.
I've taken the access off for a reason.
I'll point out later.
But it's a,
you know,
this is radio velocity versus time and
this is exactly what you expect to see.
It goes up,
it comes down a very good news.
This is exactly what you expect to see.
Uh,
for a planet.
There are two problems here.
As it turns out.
Problem number one
is the x axis
because it turns out the amount of
time it takes you to go one orbit,
uh,
around for this object is a
little more than four days.
The shortest orbital plus a period of a
planet in our own solar system is that
of mercury,
which is 88 days.
So this thing is way closer to the
star then anything in our solar system
x axis problem is that p is
equal to around four days.
Problem number two
is the y axis.
And now let me put some
units onto this thing.
I've done a very bad thing of
showing you a graph with no units,
but it was just to,
you know,
prolong the suspense here.
Uh,
visa bar zero.
So that's going sideways.
This is 50 meters a second.
This is negative 50 meters a second.
Ah,
and so first it here,
it's coming towards you there.
It's going away from you.
And so the amplitude of this thing,
and therefore the velocity of the star
is something like 50 meters a second.
Now it's less obvious
why that's a problem,
but it is.
And let me,
let me show you why.
Now let me do the equation.
Uh,
do the equations a little bit.
okay,
so this is a,
so solar analog.
What is the,
uh,
semi major access of the
planets or bed access of planet?
We know P is equal to,
uh,
let's see,
four over three.
65.24 is equal to one over a hundred is
equal to 10 to the minus two in years.
Uh,
that's four days over,
over a year.
A and M is equal to one solar
mass because it's a solar analog.
So a cube equals p squared m is
equal to 10 to the minus two squared.
M is equal to one 10 to the minus four.
So a is equal to 10 to the uh,
well let's,
we got to do this right a hundred times
10 to the minus six to the one third
power.
Uh,
five cube does a 125.
So the cube root of 100 is five,
uh,
five times 10 to the minus
two astronomical units,
uh,
or like to put it in a,
in real units here,
five times 10 to the minus
two and astronomical unit
is 1.5 times 10 to the 11
meters,
five times one and a half is like
seven times 10 to the nine meters.
So that how,
that's the semi major axis.
And if you compare it,
if you go look at the lists of
planets in our own solar system,
what you'll discover is that way closer
than any of the planets in our own solar
system,
way closer to the star than mercury is a,
I used the y axis yet.
Uh,
now I'm about to,
uh,
because what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take,
I'm going to figure out the velocity
that this planet is moving at.
That's two Pi a over p.
We wrote that down a little while ago.
A,
I just figured out,
so two times Pi Times,
uh,
seven times 10 to the nine
p is one 100th of a year.
So that's 10 to the minus two
times three times 10 to the seven,
which is the number of seconds in a year.
Pi over three is one,
uh,
two times seven is 15,
10 to the nine,
a 10 to the minus two
times 10 to the seven,
10 to the five.
Uh,
so this is 15 times 10 to the
four or 1.5 times 10 to the five.
So this thing is going
on a hunt the planet.
Now this is the total,
which is approximately equal to v planet
is going at 150 kilometers a second,
much faster than the
earth is going around.
That makes perfect sense.
It's in closer.
Got to move faster to stay in its orbit.
Uh,
and so this is 150 kilometers a
second if you prefer those units.
Now we know the velocity of the planet.
We know the mass of the star.
Uh,
we know the velocity of the star and
so we can figure out the mass of the
planet.
Here's how it works.
And Planet,
the planet is equal to m star.
The Star,
uh,
v Planet we've just figured out
is 1.5 times 10 to the five.
Uh,
actually let's leave it as
15 times 10 to the four.
That'll turn out to be
easier for the arithmetic,
the mass of the stars,
the same as the mass of the sun.
Two Times 10 to the 30.
Uh,
the velocity of the star we just observed,
we saw it moving back and forth.
It's 50 kilometers a second,
five times 10 to the one.
Okay.
So now,
and this is multiplied by
the mass of the planet.
So the mass of the planet mass of the
planet is equal to a two times 10 to the
30,
uh,
times five times 10 to the one
divided by 15 times 10 to the four.
Five over 15 is a third.
So this is a third times 10 to the minus
three times the mass of the sun tent to
a minus three times the mass of the sun.
That's the mass of Jupiter.
So this is equal to one third,
the mass of Jupiter,
which is by the way bigger than the mass
of Saturn or any other object in our
own solar system.
Okay?
So that's catastrophic,
right?
That's a hopeless disaster because the
first part of the lecture and the second
part of the lecture have
entirely contradicted each other.
Cause in the first part of the lecture
I gave you a whole song and dance.
Uh,
and you know,
you all wrote it down and it
sounded believable at the time,
how inner planets were going
to be these small rocky things.
And now the very first planet we'd
go out and find turns out to be,
uh,
a,
very close planet that quite massive,
and this is impossible according to,
uh,
this nice little fury of
planetary formation that I
promulgated to you earlier
in the lecture.
And so,
uh,
the very first a planet that was observed,
turned out to be a screw up.
A worse than that.
There were soon,
uh,
dozens more like it
discovered.
These are given the name hot Jupiters
and you could see what the problem is if
you figure out what the surface
temperature of these things ought to be.
It's that it's over a thousand degrees.
There's no way you
could have a gas or ice,
uh,
on such a thing.
It would totally melt.
Uh,
and there aren't enough rocks
in the whole rocky elements,
silicon,
uh,
and iron and so forth in the whole of
the planetary system of our own solar
system to,
to add up to one third of the Jupiter,
even if you put them all together.
So how is this done?
What is,
what is going on here?
Uh,
it seems clear that one of
two things must be true.
Either this thing isn't a planet
and there's some other explanation,
uh,
for this,
attractive bunch of data here or
something has gone seriously wrong in our
understanding of how planets form.
Uh,
and,
uh,
stay tuned.
We'll talk about that next time.